If you remember our program works going through the individual states of the finite state machine,
you will find that this input is not processed correctly.
What we have in here in our input is the character that can also be mistaken
for the end of tag in HTML markup.
A program does not know about the special meaning of double quotes, so what it does is--
it starts interpreting everything as HTML but only up to the closing tag.
The double quote in here is interpreted as text input.
The greater than sign is ignored even in a non-tag mode. The text is doing just fine.
And the remaining HTML markup is ignored.
So what we should get as output is double quote foo and you can see that the output
still contains part of the original HTML markup.
So this is the correct answer. The others all work fine. Let me demonstrate this in the IDE.
Since I'm now having double quotes in my script, I use single quotes in Python,
which I can also use to delimit a string.
Rule of thumb--if your string contains double quotes, use single quotes as string delimiters.
If your string contains single quotes, use double quotes as delimiters.
If there's no quotes in your string, well feel free whatever you like.
Here's our input with greater than and double quotes, we run the whole thing,
and we see that the output indeed contains part of the HTML markup
that is the double quote is still in there.